welcome everybody to another YouTube
hang out super excited to be here with a
new guest Keith washoe keith is an
author he has written the heart of
success and we're going to talk today
about how to live the right way so Keith
welcome aboard thank you haven't it's an
honor to be on your show a big fan thank
you it's a pleasure to be here so for
people who don't know what about you
what you're all about give us like the
32nd overview of Keith washoe and then a
little bit about the book too sure yeah
so overview I'm from grew up in New York
near Canada and Rochester my dad worked
for Kodak education wise and went to
university of new york at oswego and
then i went to university of miami for
grad school and then went got my MBA at
st. Mary's and I've been working a
Silicon Valley for last 16 years for
tech companies like Qualcomm sandisk
creative labs where now meta data sound
technologies and then basically wrote a
book two years ago after learning a lot
and Silicon Valley and getting the NBA
and writing a lot and had opportunity to
put all the experience and then I
interviewed executives to share wisdom
on how do you grow in your life in the
right way both professionally and
personally got it so that that's what
has culminated into this book the heart
of success all these interviews with
successful tech entrepreneurs and
executives yeah so basically i spent
about a year interviewing us executives
and I'd like to give you an example I
can read off a couple of them so I met
with mat Hoffman twins who had to
crunchbase i interviewed mark adams
who's the president of micron
technologies kevin connelly who was the
GM a senior VP at sandisk Toby Preston
who's vp of sales at qualcomm so I have
over a dozen different people that I
interviewed and I asked him all the same
questions what's helped you succeed
personally in your life not only in
business where you hit your numbers and
you you cheat great success for the
company but also most importantly that a
special essence of being a good father
of being a good husband of being a good
friend being a good brother and I really
try to go after that and that special
mix hence the heart of success God is so
so now y'all now I'm dying to know what
are some of the things that you've
learned that you mean you gotta pick up
the book but you know give us an
overview sure I think
the key essence of the book and what it
tries to impart on you after all the
interviews after all the wisdom with
quotes and cartoons it's really about
this one quote that kind of captures
what I would call the essence of the
heart of success so if I could read this
one quote to you it basically was
written by ralph waldo emerson and who
would believe that he'd be the one that
really inspire the heart of success on
this it says to laughed often and much
to win the respect of intelligent people
and the affection of children to earn
the appreciation of honest critics and
endure the betrayal of false friends
appreciate beauty to find the best in
others and to leave the world a bit
better whether by a healthy child or a
garden patch or redeemed social
condition to know that even one life has
breathed easier because you have lived
this is to have succeeded and so this
book really goes on on that spirit of
personal and professional success but
doing it in the right way to wholesome
way so what what is look if you had
maybe three things that you would say
that these guys are doing differently or
these these guys have figured out that
others haven't or haven't yet well what
would your top 3 be the top three are
would when you interviewed everybody and
you kind of stream out and polish up
that stone the top three things are
listening do what you love hard work and
those three are in case with a beautiful
crossing of perseverance so I'll give
you an example so listening that was
really the top you wouldn't think I'll
listening like so try it so simple but
all the executive that listening was the
most important thing that's helped them
in their careers and you've probably
heard the quote I've in that God gave us
two ears and one mouth for a reason so
we hear hear more and speak less and and
the whole point of listening was that's
the only way you truly learn and
understand what's going on in the world
by listening and thinking and
comprehending secondly when you're
working
people and all of our success is about
relationships with other people
listening allows you to understand
people better but here's the thing it
helps them feel respected appreciated
trusted by you because listening opens
up that door automatically so listening
was so so important and they put that at
the top of the list that's why in the
book I start off with listening as the
key any questions on that partner I like
it and you know people watching is
saying that they love the quote at the
start like wow how beautiful so so you
got some some really fans already oh
that's nice so listen is the first one
yeah yeah so though the other one is do
what you love and you probably heard
things Evan I think actually some of
your videos that I've watched in the
interviews people said hey the harder I
work the luckier I get and and and the
point is by doing what you love you can
work hard because you love it you're in
you're in passionate just like all these
videos you do that's a lot of work but
you love making these videos it's you're
inspired from within so hard work and
the key as they say is is elbow grease
just got to roll up your sleeves and do
it and one of the sales executives we
interview from Acer computer says you
have to be willing to carry the bag and
that's a simple quota meeting get out
there you get on the plains to trains
automobiles you shake hands you meet
with people you do the excel sheets you
do the numbers just work hard he says
where your company's colors so you just
just give everything you got and that
way like Rocky Balboa you work hard
you'll see the results and you can hold
up your glove at the end of the day you
know victorious on the the last point is
that not doing what you love is that
because you've heard that if you love
what you do time flies and you get
caught up in it and life is happy and
peaceful because you're doing what your
heart and you're called to do when your
genetic and DNA so doing a little you
love listening hard work are the three
central themes and then the last one is
the glaze what you call perseverance
because in one of your videos Steve Jobs
says you gotta be able to persevere
because shuffling a technology business
it's hard things are changing
competitive forces and if you don't love
what you do you don't
held the work hard you don't persevere
through this he says you're going to
quit and give up because it's hard and
so that's why you need perseverance to
see it through and the best movie that
we can all relate to is rudy rudy is an
example of giving failure falling on his
face Rudy persevered and what happens
you know you guess the plane gets
carried off the field and it's that is
that theme what I love about it is I
mean you went off and interviewed
executives where most of the people
watching this channel the content that I
put those with you for entrepreneurs but
the characteristics are the same like
those lessons will say almost every day
on the channel to that you can peer and
over and over again and what it really
highlights for at least for me is that
you know success in any field comes down
to those things not just as an
entrepreneur not just as a musician not
just as an executive not just as you
know fill in the blank but to succeed at
whatever you want to do you have to have
those those traits and those
characteristics and follow through on
them exactly the end of the day Evan
it's all about people and relationships
with people whether you're an
entrepreneur whether you're working on
your home by yourself or working at a
big company the ability to get along and
with other people and then to deliver
results and value and that's where the
hard work comes in the perseverance
listening to other people doing what you
love so you bring the fire you bring the
passion it's it's it's almost like it's
not rocket science but the the trick of
it all is is doing it is is executing
all this things hence having the rocket
fuel to boost the rocket Keith what made
you want to write this book right so
this book came out as an inspiration of
a couple things first I'm a big sucker
for like hearts and love and and
understanding like you are what makes
people successful I had that inner
craving desire to understand that so
it's a book I wanted to write for myself
like I generally was curious on what
does it mean to succeed not from the
books that i have seen in rent on
professionally and climbing the
corporate ladder and getting along with
people that's all good but i wanted to
take an approach that I haven't seen
which was succeeding there yes and
here's trace to succeed professionally
but I wanted to really focus in on the
balance
how do you succeed personally as well so
you you're great with your family and
kids and your friends and at work and so
you live this kind of wholesome balance
well centered life so I didn't really
see a book out there and it was
something that was generally interested
in so went out and wrote that book
around that and the other thing is you
know I just spent two years at st.
Mary's getting my MBA writing a ton of
papers I felt like I had the extra
studies to support writing this book and
lastly I've been working in Silicon
Valley for 16 years so I had access to
executives and a lot of these companies
who I could interview so it was the
access the education and the passion and
the subject matter that made me write
the book as weeds is interesting is as
I've we've done profiles of really
successful people who are highly driven
ah then you're doing really well in
their career but if you look at their
personal life they may not be all that
great and they often talk about
sacrifices you have to sacrifice you
know the personal life to have the
professional excellence and success so
obviously your book is challenging that
and I'm curious as to when you win
you're reaching out and trying to find
these executives who had that success on
both fronts was that part of the
criteria before even interviewing them
is like you're trying to find guys who
had the balance on both I'm with the
people who you know you interviewed and
and you found that they didn't have a
good person life and so you didn't want
to include them I I'm just curious how
do they how does let's go that's an
incredible in-depth zinger question
great question first off let me say that
every executive I interviewed when it
came to work life balance and there's a
chapter dedicated to work life balance
they all admittedly said hey I'm gonna
give you all the advice I can but I
automated this is something that I
struggle with the most so put it out
there that they all felt like they
needed to do better in that department
now they actually questioned how I chose
the executives to interview everyone one
was a VP GM or CEO of a company in
Silicon Valley so that was one of the
criteria secondly they were people that
I worked with and known who I have seen
the character of summary look at say you
know they're a really good person yet
are successful but there's someone who
have good positive
energy who are loving likeable and
thoroughly yeah all we were married
almost all of them had kids so they had
this this kind of thing balance a
personal like that they had to work
through granted no one's perfect some of
them had divorces everyone has bumps
along the way but but overall the list
was comprised of executives and high-end
positions who have proven successes in
companies who also were great character
people and had big personalized like
family kids grandkids for the people who
are watching who want to get more be
more successful as it as a person in
their relationships all that as well as
have the entrepreneurial side I think we
I think a lot of the content out there
only focuses on professional success or
personal success but not mixing them
what are some of the what are some of
the things that you found from the
people you interviewed on the personal
side that they did regularly that helped
them stay balanced and live you know the
right way right so in the book I me to
show you one of the chapters that
answers that question there's a chapter
called being effective with people how
to be successful with people is like the
main chapter that covers that and then
the other part is the work/life balance
that answers that so what I found from
all the executives was this is
interesting they said you know we're
executives in Silicon Valley working
these tech companies we have millions
demands on our time we're always
scheduling meetings and appointments
they said lookit you need to schedule
your family vacation times just as
important as your two o'clock sales
meeting so they would all scheduled
dedicated time am i picking my son up
from school I'm going to this soccer
game I'm doing this family vacation on
this week and they would lock it in and
they would prioritize these personal
things as important if not sometimes
more important than some of these work
things but it's again it's that balance
the other part was the importance of
when it comes to these the relationships
with people on a personal level they
always set that meeting in person
talking face to face is so much better
than these phone calls and emails now a
day that really have taken over our
so they would all make it a point to
have in person talks and then the third
part of that is just be sincere and
honest with people and all you say and
all you do and the last thing on how
they were able to be successful with
people overall in the career both
professionally and personally was they
came down to this is where there's a
chapter dedicated on faith they all said
it's about living the golden rule treat
others as you would like to be treated
do unto others as you would like done
unto you and when you take that and you
put it all together that's where they
found the heart of success I love it in
thinking about you write this book I'm
assuming you already knew a lot of this
stuff and was great at it kind of
reinforce just just by your character in
the fact you wanted to write this book
and you're seeking out answers I'm
curious though so I'm sure you already
knew a lot of the stuff they were saying
I'm curious what you learned that was
unexpected that was different that you
didn't already go in thinking about from
some of these people some lessons that
like you thought ah I can apply that to
my career or to my personal life as well
well the first thing is I didn't realize
that listening would be would boil up as
the most important part of success that
I almost called the book listen up
because of that and so they came chapter
one because how important listening was
so we really double down to my conscious
effort of the importance of listening
and beat in a meeting listen more speak
glass and so that probably bubbled up to
me is like wow I didn't expect that the
other thing that was fascinating that
I'd ended up dedicating a chapter to was
staying fresh they said that you have to
constantly learn be a lifelong learner
was one of the themes keep going to
professional development classes keep
going to conferences keep going to
seminars keep reading a leader is a
reader things like that so the
importance of staying fresh in your
career I'd end up dedicating a chapter
to which came out from all the
executives some of them are in their 60s
and they're still running technology
companies I mean a lot of people retire
when they're 65 some of them are like 68
and still like GM
yos and still running everyday learning
every day so that that stood out did you
learn anything on how to be a better
listener from them or could you give
advice on how to be a better listener
that if that's like the biggest thing
you learned and one of the biggest you
almost called the book listen up it's a
key for success as a corporate executive
as an entrepreneur so now I'm taking as
an entrepreneur I want to have more
success okay how can I listen better are
there any is there a path to follow is
it just the awareness or their steps
that you need to take how can we become
better listeners so in in in the book
chapter two is called how to be an
effective listener and it gives all the
wisdom on that but the most important
thing they said was first is when you
listen to people like simple things
right like we said this is blocking and
tackling but it's about execution look
them in the eye okay and and give them
your full attention how many times you
talk to people and they're typing away
or they're on the phone oh yeah what's
up or typing and kind of looking at you
stop put things down look people in the
eyes give them your full attention and
that requires not looking only looking
at them but nodding showing
acknowledgement like you're you're
engaged so being engaged listener the
second thing was once you hear then you
pick up on things they said it's
fantastic take notes write down what
they're saying things I sent out to you
then the third step was reiterate back
so let me know what I'm hearing is that
a B and C is that we're trying to say
yeah yeah okay great so now they fully
feel respected listen to you acknowledge
you heard what they said that's the art
of listening I love it well it's gets a
couple questions to the people who are
watching I reaching come TV is saying
one of the chapters in your book is
successful products so I guess she's
already looking into your book once all
about uh one of the chapters in your
book is successful products and she's
asking how do you determine what a
successful product is so when you work
in Silicon Valley like I have for
creative labs and SanDisk and and and
Bigfoot networks
bent your life marketing and selling
consumer electronics which I have you
learn a lot about what makes a product
successful and so I dedicate a chapter
on that because professionally if you
want to succeed you want to be able to
make products which drives all the
revenue a lot for companies successful
so some of the keys that came out worse
with like again these sound like simple
things we're number one when you come
out with a product and Steve Jobs always
did this at apple and this was made
apple famous start with the consumer in
mind first and what that means is you
don't start with elijah school
technology let me go find a home for it
oh because i have this technology we we
should do this Steve Jobs says that
doesn't work they try that with some of
their other products and they failed
start with what is the customers pain
point what do they really need were they
creating for what's missing and how can
we deliver that to them and do it in the
best way possible so start with the
customer in mind that was the first rule
of thumb for a great product and then
the second Lee is that your traditional
MBA stuff that's why I dedicate a check
part of the chapter on the 5 p's product
pricing positioning knowing where to put
the product how to message it
successfully which we talked about in
the book um the third thing and I think
one of the most important things is
built not only building for the customer
first and doing all the proper NBA stuff
on the 5 p's of marketing for it but
it's making sure that the product is
something that when people use they're
gonna love and want to tell their
friends about it that whole
evangelization thing that came out of
Apple people waiting in line for ipod
and iphones because they love the
product and then they tell people about
it if you make a product that people put
in their hands and they love and they
want to touch and use everyday people
call it the tube brush rule a product
that people want to you know have to use
or want to use every day that you know
you have a successful product love it
maybe as a segue zeno is writing in to
say Keith how do you define success if I
may define success for you there's a a
poem in the book that's called the dash
it's about takes me about 30 seconds to
read it but is that all right advocate
of time for that let's hear the dash
this poem is the essence of the heart of
success and how I would define success
and it was written by Lee Linda Alice
and it's called the dash it says I read
of a man who stood to speak at the
funeral of a friend he referred to the
date of her tombstone from beginning to
the end he noted that first came the
date of her birth and spoke of the
following date with tears but he said
what mattered most of all was that dash
between those years for that dash
represented all the time that she spent
alive on earth and now only those who
loved her know what that little line is
worth for it matters not how much we own
the cars the house the cash what matters
is how we live and love and how we spend
our dash so think about this long and
hard are there things you like to change
for you never know how much time is left
that can still be rearranged if we could
just slow down enough to consider what's
true and real and always try to
understand the way other people feel and
be less quick to anger and show
appreciation more and love the people in
our lives like we've never loved before
if we treat each other with respect and
more often wear a smile remembering that
this special dash might only last a
while so when your eulogy is being read
with your life's actions to rehash would
you be proud of the things they say
about how you spent your dash I love it
I love it I think in addition to an
author we got to add professional reader
or something credentials airy I love it
it's great
um cool was you know it's amazing how
time flies when you're having fun keep
people want to learn more about you and
we're with the book what's the best
place to connect they can just go to my
website it's keith Washoe calm which is
my name ke ith my last name Washoe WA sa
Choe calm and there you can get
information on my book and more about me
and I'm happy to help or answer any
questions for anybody I love it will
link that up in the description below
for you guys ki thank you so much your
time thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon believe